let's go to the phones at (617) 830-4750 and
see what's on people's minds.
Starting with our caller from the four zero
one area code.
Who's calling today from four zero one
Hey David, my name's Kenny.
How you doing?
How's it going?
I'm doing well.
Um, first time caller, long time listener,
uh, recently picked up a membership since
you've been doing such great coverage of the
primaries.
I wanted to call.
So I'm actually out here at UC Berkeley on
a graduate student and I'm sure you've heard
about the strike that's going on in Santa
Cruz.
I wanted to get your take on it because I'm
a pretty active member with the union here
on campus and as you know, this is a Wildcat
strike that, uh, isn't endorsed by the union
officially and, uh, for political reasons
I won't be putting in my 2 cents, but, uh,
I want to get your take next.
You know, I just don't really know enough
about the circumstances to be able to comment.
I know that when I was an undergrad at the
university of Massachusetts, there would very
often be a varieties of different types of
either protests or strikes from the graduate
student, uh, organizations or different groups.
And I, I just feel like it would be inappropriate
for me to really weigh in because I don't,
I'm aware of it.
I don't know all the circumstances and, uh,
I just don't think there's any, any benefit
to me giving an uninformed opinion about something
so specific.
So then can I ask you a more general question?
Um, given what we did, what we've seen recently
with big labor pushing back on things like
Medicare for all and attacking the Sanders
agenda because of some of the quote unquote
things that they fought for so far.
Um, what role do you think big labor has to
play in something like this?
Do you think that worker strikes can be effective
without big labor?
Um, and where do you think that or what do
you think the university of California, I
guess that's specific.
So let's, let's just stop there.
As far as big labor goes.
So I, I believe that it is, um, completely
incorrect to suggest that Medicare for all,
as an example, is something that big labor
as you call it, should oppose because it takes
out of, uh, the sort of negotiating package
or what's under the umbrella of big labor
to do for their union members.
In fact, I saw an analysis that was, that
was different, which is if you take something
like healthcare out of the negotiation, big
labor, because you have a Medicare for all
program, big labor now can specifically know
the number of dollars per employee that were
previously being spent on health insurance
and can argue that there should be raises
at least for some part of what that savings
is.
So I reject completely the idea that a on
principle big labor should be opposed to something
like Medicare for all.
And I don't believe all big labor is, I mean,
we heard from some union unions that, uh,
activate, excuse me, activated around that
issue.
Um, but it has not been all of them.
And I, I just don't buy that for a second.
I think that that's a talking point meant
to stifle supportive, progressive candidates
and it's a talking point meant to support
a stifle supportive Medicare for all.
Interesting.
Yeah.
David Dolan had a similar, not completely
the same take, but uh, in a similar vein.
So thanks.
Um, last thing.
Where can I find the show being live streamed
right now?
If I'm a member.
Yeah.
Oh we don't, uh, we don't stream the show
live.
The show is produced in the afternoon and
then released a few hours later.
So only only like the evening livestreams
are actually available, available live.
Kenny, thank you so much for the call.
I appreciate hearing from you.
Let's go next to our caller from the seven
six Oh area code call from seven six.
Oh, who's this?
Where are you calling from?
Seven.
Six.
So are you, we muted because we've got you
on, but we can't hear you.
Seven six.
Oh, I heard something click.
This'll be the last opportunity.
Are
you there?
Seven.
Six Oh, all right.
Seven six.
So clearly having an issue of sounded like
we were muted.
I heard like an unmute noise and then alas,
we had to get rid of the call.